il est surnommé le double mutants par
les médias indiens
son nom b 1 617 il est catégorisé variés
of interest par le site at break point
info double mutants car ce dernier
cumulerait une mutation semblable aux
variants californien et une autre
similaire aux variants sud africain et
brésilien
une mutation qui le rend plus contagieux
est une mutation qui le rendrait moins
accessibles au système immunitaire
c'est-à-dire à la protection vaccinale
ils représentent près de 55% des cas de
contamination
il s'agit de 55 % des nouveaux cas dans
l'état du maharashtra qui abrite
notamment bombay et la ville de nagpur
où était découvert ce variant en octobre
dernier
b 1 617 serait donc responsable d'une
nouvelle vague de contamination dans le
sous continent
on ne sait pas grand chose sur ce
variant que ce soit au niveau de sa
dangerosité ou de sa résistance au
vaccin mais d'après les propos rapportés
par le huffington post il pourrait être
plus contagieux que le virus initiale au
niveau scientifique
ce variant soulève de nombreuses
interrogations on sait qu'il est associé
à l'explosion actuelle que subit l'inde
mais il est toujours compliqué de
distinguer causes et conséquences
toutefois certaines des mutations qu'il
porte ont été décrites dans d'autres
lignes et de variants et pourrait être
associé à une contagiosité plus élevés
voire un échappement immunitaire face
aux inquiétudes que provoque ce variant
certains pays ont déjà pris des mesures
c'est le cas par exemple du royaume uni
qui interdit tout entrer sur son
territoire aux voyageurs en provenance
d'inde
sauf pour les résidents britanniques qui
devront tout de même se soustraire à un
isolement obligatoire du côté de la
france si nous devons prendre une mesure
sur l'inde nous l'apprendrons a affirmé
le secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes sur l'antenne de france info
à ce jour près de 200 cas de ce double
mutants ont déjà été répertoriés en
europe